hallo leute hier sind eure meinung
willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender aus punk wie ja ich weiß
wie viele kommen noch bis zum ersten
dezember werden jetzt noch ein benziner
kommt dann ist die ganze sache vorbei
ich wollte diesen adventskalender
eigentlich privat benutzen weil ich den
im september bestellt habe und der kam
jetzt erst vor einer woche an und dann
dachte ich mir so ja kommen dann bindet
sich den einfach für mich selbst sind
habe ich denn heute wohl aufgemacht um
ihn aufzustellen mir ist aufgefallen was
das für ein riesen ding eigentlich ist
man eher an
ich kenne die firma tizian und nicht so
wirklich ich weiß sie haben deko und das
ist ein weihnachtlicher deko
adventskalender ich habe ja schon mal
den westring adventskalender ausgepackt
und ich wollte jetzt nicht noch mal den
gleichen auspackt deswegen tiziano sind
hier riesenpaket ich denke es wird viel
verpackungsmaterial sei aber ja wir ihn
einfach mal rein und was sagt ihr zu
übertrieben heute jetzt weiß ich warum
es mir so dunkel vorkommt mein gott ich
habe ein licht vergessen
jetzt besser fürs geld was
adventskalender gekostet also ich hab
den am ersten september bestellt und der
kam ja jetzt vor einer woche an und habe
95 dafür ausgegeben es ist eine stange
geld es handelt sich hier aber ja und
deko also wird es wohl sein preiswert
sein genau tiziano
design und die motion steht hier werden
unsere emotions heute rausgeholt wir
wissen jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken
dass ich die nummer 1 könnte so o pop
und bevor jemand was falsches vermutet
dieses videos nicht gesponsert und jetzt
alle dieses videos nicht gesponsert
let's go ich hätte den auch gerne selber
benutzt ich finde also ich bin komplett
überrascht davon wie das hier alles
angekommen ist wie groß und wie viel das
ich glaube das ist auch so ein perfekter
multitalent also wenn ihr eure mutter so
richtig was gewollt nächstes jahr ich
denke ich dass man den noch kriegt dann
macht es mit diesem kalender
dieser adventskalender reise nummer eins
luftpolsterfolie
ich glaube es ist ganz cool dass ich das
schon vorher auf machen bei mir fehlt so
ein bisschen weihnachtsdeko ich habe
hier schon aber finde bei
weihnachtscircus aber mehr einfach nie
und jetzt darf man mittlerweile ja auch
in weihnachtsstimmung sein
[Gelächter]
hallo auch gott das ist ja wirklich das
ist weihnachten das ist so schön
das ist so kitschig aber so schöne
theorie nicht hassen
ich bin für mein gott ist das schön
türchen nummer zwei packungen haben die
wirklich ernst genommen allerdings kann
die sachen aus schneit so betrieben auch
ich heule
höher
das ist wirklich ein du hast ja
wunderbar zu unserem nikolaus hier
wieder mal
34 mut das ist ja mal ein richtiges baby
dann passt alles ganz fantastisch guckt
man stehe ich dazu sagen wunderbar von
der qualität absolut hochwertig ich weiß
jetzt nicht auf den großen unterschied
gibt sozusagen nun da sage ich mal oder
die ganzen anderen die kollegen und die
wirklich die qualität sich hier
unterscheidet aber es sieht sehr
hochwertig auch sehr tolle nummer vier
ist schwer sagen wie es ist ich packe
gerade 24 geschenke aus ich freue mich
gerade ich bin einfach glücklich holt
holt und das sieht so ein bisschen sehr
das kann da auch eine wunderbare
steckdose seien ja da gemacht man vier
kerzen heute ist der erste advent aber
das erste türchen macht man erst am
mittwoch auf die sind blöd aber sehr
schön elegant bis wie eine badewanne
natürlichen nummer fünf
bambis mutter der schönen nächsten höher
schauen wie's vater
ich glaube sind nur weise wie kunden
drin
soll ich musste ganz miesen ich glaube
dass es irgendwie staub oder irgendwas
vier staubig ich es eigentlich nur bei
stau oder wenn ich krank werde nicht
kurz vor lauda vielleicht von den
wimpern kleber irgendwie es der wimper
kleber in letzter zeit ganz schön
aggressiv türchen nummer sechs es ist
nikolaus von tiziano hat wieder etwas
weißes für uns aber natürlich passend
zum nikolaus nikolaus
bisschen also seine pose so herget
schild und ich werde jetzt ganz viele
figuren haben ich muss sie auf jeden
fall ein paar verschenken das musste mal
passieren ist das jetzt eine 7 oder 19
das ist die 7 das ist die sieht man sie
während ekström mit led beleuchtung war
es leuchtet hier ein haus in led
beleuchtung
es dann gemütlich und es hat sogar ein
timer das heißt man macht es allerdings
ein paar stunden aus und am nächsten tag
um die gleiche uhrzeit geht es wieder an
heute nicht wo sind die timerfunktion
irrt jetzt wirst dir viel zusage zu den
sachen kann man ja nicht mehr kann ich
ja allgemein mal über meine gemacht weil
meine pläne rede zum ersten dezember
gibt es jetzt noch adventskalender
riegel dann gibt es im dezember ja
videos zu den sonntagen wieder bis
weihnachten ich freue mich drauf es gibt
dieses jahr leider kein blog mails ich
habe nämlich in den letzten jahren
gemerkt das ist einfach zu viel essig
schaffte es nicht machen die
weihnachtszeit ein bisschen mies weil
ich so viel zu tun habe und eigentlich
ja die weihnachtszeit genießen möchte
deswegen habe ich mich dafür entschieden
eine glitzer schneekugel das motiv ja
ich mag ganz ehrlich wenn da so reh oder
so drin sind oder weihnachtsmann ist
auch für schneekugeln haben schon etwas
besonderes an sich oder irgendwie sind
sie als kind fand ich das auch mal schon
so toll wir haben jetzt ein bisschen
glauben so einen klassischen nikolaus
wären einen lustigen nikolaus haben wir
noch nicolai in einer schneekugel in
tütchen noch mal neu etwas ganz anderes
sein irgendwas aus stroh
stroh irgendwas austanzte und ich glaube
die haben einfach weiter sagt
wird aber kein thema hier
ich muss ein paar verschenken ich glaube
an die hat nicht so viel weihnachtsdeko
die könnte auf jeden fall was davon
gebrauchen habe sie ja doch katzen und
wenn katzen sowas umwerfen
ich habe auch den menschen um mich herum
schon mal angekündigt dass ich nächstes
jahr einen adventskalender selber machen
möchtest du bist klappt aber es wäre
sehr sehr cool der druck ist sehr hoch
jetzt natürlich immer ein klassisches
schön aber das würde ich schon als
kitschig bezeichnet findet ihr das
krippe hier den strasssteinen finde ich
ein bisschen kitschig mit dem herz in
der hand auch riesig für die mama wenn
ihr das jetzt hier schön für mich
dadurch nicht gelöst nummer 11 auf
meinem tisch wird es langsam lehrer
also hier haben wir eine glocke kommt an
unseren tenenbaum ran wie im fall ein
bisschen groß ist sie für den tannenbaum
bringt man so eine glocke sonst auf
der minister was haltet ihr davon nummer
12 weil er hälfte sind wir schon an
gekauft jetzt machen wir hier schnell
leute das geht hier versagt sagt eine
sache wie noch gelesen ich konsumiere ja
nicht alles was in diesen advents
gehören drin ist das ist einfach ein
schönes format was ich gerne mache weil
ich adventskalender lieben aber den
inhalt habe ich jetzt zum beispiel auf
instagram verloren viel geld verteilt
also bei mir bleibt wirklich nur ein
paar produkte ich hole nicht diese
ganzen adventskalender weil ich selber
ganzen produkte haben möchte also das
wäre wirklich sehr viel konsum nur dass
jedes mal versteht dass ich alleine
neuen kalender verlost das ist ja eine
kiste ist die kleinste keksdose der welt
sehr kritikwürdig ttt könnte man
reinmachen sein lieblings weihnachtszeit
jemand sowas versuche ich noch selber zu
töpfern also etwas mit einem deckel aber
noch habe ich nicht geschafft 13 hier
das ist wirklich also ein weißer weko
kalender ohne ende aber da muss man ja
da muss man auf jeden fall sehr auf das
weiße decke zeug stehen bin team alles
ich mag jede art von deco weiß es so ein
bisschen ziemlich badezimmer also
vielleicht dekoriert mit vielen sachen
mein badezimmer damit schon viel deko
das sieht auch sehr handgemacht aus die
sind groß aber handgemacht nummer 14
meine damen und herren willkommen zur
auftaktsendung mit ihrer moderatorin
vanessa mal was verbirgt sich hinter
türchen nummer 14
[Musik]
die ist ja pretty das ist mein
baumschmuck leute ja baumschmuck hätten
sie mehr reinpacken ich merke dass so
baumschmuck es geht schon ganz gut
so hochwertig
ist gerade eine neue runde ist glück was
verbirgt sich hinter dem schwarz und
creme
viel luftpolsterfolie verbirgt sich
hinter dem türchen nummer 15 oder kann
man kerzen reinmachen wir haben wieder
anderen kitschigen engel und es sieht
aus wie engel hält ein herz in der hand
für mich sah es auf dem ersten blick
anders aus
und dann kommt da so eine schöne kerze
ich weiß nicht ich bin engel sind schon
schön aber hasen das ist irgendwie nicht
so ganz meine schwester die deko lieben
die hat so viel weiß ich ich schicke
meine schwester war die wir das lieben
ich glaube dass ist genau ihr ding
ein bisschen was und meine schwester 16
ist auch wieder ein mächtiges paket als
geschwister und es ist wieder
quadratisch
was ist das
wir haben die erste farbe dass eine vase
oder eine sehr lange keksdose ich würde
es ich will sich als basis steht nach
soli für base sind na klar es ist eine
soli fleur phase habe ich auch im ersten
moment erkannt nummer 17 hinter dem
türchen nummer 17 h wir haben wieder
anton bauer wunderschönen wunderschön
ganz tolle weihnachtsdeko
18 super schön es ist fantastisch
wow wow das sieht toll aus ein stern da
kann man eine kerze reinmachen ganz toll
super nummer 19 8 für das vorhaben werde
man der müllberg neben ihr wird gerade
sehr sehr groß was ist es doch
da kenne ich mein geld rein machen dies
nicht wahr mache ich eine kerze rein
hier oben kommen die mails die ich ende
märz ihr twens kalender bekommen haben
dann duftet es mir die wohnung voll
weil ich habe noch gedacht jetzt extra
so ein ding bestellen aber jetzt habe
ich einen hammer und sid judo also das
ist schick ich schade dass hier kein
kielerin ist so eine tolle kann er mit
einem teelicht darunter
schmuck passt ja also die wollten
bestimmt total coolen weil die sterne
halt nicht so eine richtige aber es
sieht aus wie sterne die man als kind
gemalt hat und man konnte halt nicht
richtige sterne malen dann hat man halt
so komisch ihre sterne gemalt so sehen
die sterne so ein bisschen aus wie cute
dazu erst ein kevin allein zu haus
gedacht wann es gibt er die szene wo
kevin der tauben frau diese darf es also
diese tauben schenkt diese weisen als
baumschmuck
und das hätte ich das das wirkung 21
es ist ja doch es ist aber kein bisschen
22 vanessa du hast gar keine richtige
lust in diesem video avi emotions mit
kann man einen kalender griff
lasst mich ich weiß das ich ist alles
verschenken werden und nach dem
zwanzigsten porzellan diego kann ich mir
auch keine begeisterung aus den fingern
saugen also gebt gas was ihr krieg von
gestern sich gesagt habe finde ich
einsame spitze das benutze ich immer
eine make up insel und jetzt fragt ihr
euch aber wenn das war wie viele make-up
insel hast du sehr viel ich habe sehr
viel so stift mega pinsel zeug dieses
perfekte
die begeisterung ist zurück 23
polizisten
die adventszeit ist wir haben den
kalender nicht an einem tag auf fristen
unsere wohnung ist schon voller weißer
porzellan weko und hier haben sie es mal
wieder auf super sicher dass kontaktiert
schlaf nach ist das schön das bin ich an
weihnachten wenn ich gezwungen werde
weihnachtslieder zu singen von außen ein
engel aber von in düsseldorf wieder mal
so ein richtig schönes klassisches
weihnachtsmotiv auch wieder von der
marke chiquita und falls sie ihr das
nicht als deko benutzen wollte können
eure kinder damit spielen so es ist der
wir hatten eine tolle zeit mit weißem
porzellan alle sind da die ganze familie
ist vereint
die vierte welle ist auch da aber ich
mein mann hat sich getestet man ist
vielleicht gehen und wie man freut sich
einfach ein bisschen normalität zu
führen wenn man eltern gefahren ist oder
zu seiner familie da hat man sich das
türchen natürlich mitgenommen und man
bekommt ja er noch mal ein leuchtendes
heil jetzt ist meine leucht kollektion
vollständig wunderbar hand hast du jetzt
muss ich einmal gucken handgearbeitete
keramik rahmig stimmt tizian verkauft
ceramica offiziellen verkauf weiße deko
das ist deren ding gar sorry da will ich
mich gar nicht beschweren ja tizian
verkauft weiß deko das ist deren
steckenpferd lieben weiße keramik wenn
man sich einen tiziano adventskalender
bestellt dann weiß man ganz genau was
man kriegt weiße decke und es ist ja
wirklich kyu und ich habe auch weiße
deko im schlafzimmer und ich glaube ich
werde auch einige dinge benutzt nähe zum
beispiel den liebe ich weiß nicht warum
die global wunderbar der tannenbaum
fantastisch ja und ansonsten sind weiter
dick war ich hab ihn bestellt weil ich
irgendwo gelesen hab das ding ganz viele
leute toll finden und ich wollte einfach
mal ausprobieren ich finde auch es ist
eine tolle auswahl an weißer
weihnachtsdeko weißer keramik wir sehen
uns morgen schon beim vorletzten
adventskalender video für dieses jahren
kommt noch einer anreisen und dann ist
es schon wieder vorbei das erste
dezember und ich lehne mich aus timo ist
und hinter kommt schon wieder ganz laut
ich mach jetzt schluss bis dann ich
packe jetzt ein paket für meine
schwester wie wird sich freuen